um would you if your man was making like  very good money  like really good  and he told like okay I'm on a cheat not  cheat not even just sex with other women  what you're doing like good money  like he's very comfortable you're very  he's looking after you times  how old am I  [Music]  no I feel like I'm 45 I'm like you know  what at this point what am I gonna do  right now right now right you married  you've been you know do you have a kid  yes I've had a cat I'd be so irritated  but like you didn't tell me this before  I had the child  um if I if I had a kid I'd stay cause  it's just not about you anymore but I  would leave if I didn't have a kid  because in my head like  I don't know I just I'm big on family  and I think it was really good growing  up that I my parents just were like they  only have dated each other like they're  the only significant other both of them  have had and I think that's just like  better